abone ol
[Alkış]
[Müzik]
A1 sınıfı bitirmiştim okulunun yıl sonu
etkinliklerinde beni spiker olarak
görevlendirmiş lerdi te dikse geleceğime
öğrendiğim gün direk Bu halı Gözümde
canlandı Çünkü o zaman da aynı bu
sahnedeki halı gibi bir halı vardı
sıradaki gösteri ananas ananas etmek
için saniye koşarken bu halının köşesine
takılın bir yere kapaklandı mama
kapaklamak ve uçtum böyle ve orası daha
büyük bir Salonu ve herkes Çığlık
kıyamet gününün gülüyordu bana Ben olsam
ben de giderdim Ama
tabii çocuksu duygular ağlamıştım rezil
olduğunu düşünmüştüm utanmıştım
şimdi o zamandan yarım kalan Hikayemiz
burada tamamlayayım takımın içeriye
geldim gördünüz mü
Herkese merhaba ben falan Yüksel 1988
Ankara doğumluyum İstanbul'da yaşıyorum
Abant İzzet bu Üniversitesi Turizm ve
otel işletmeciliği mezunuyum
okuduğum bölümle alakalı yapmış olduğum
tek iş bir aylık sıkıcı moda zorunluydu
O yüzden
ben bir direkt koyunum drag Queen nedir
diye aklınızdan geçirenler vardır ki
bence
en yakın dinliyordu değil mi bir kısmını
da mutlaka dijital dünyada
karşılaşmazsınız dır çünkü netflix sağ
olsun hepimize görünür hale getirdi
Ben size bu sözcüğü tanımlamak yerine
konuşmalarımı aralarında parantezler
açık böyle daha detayına inerek
anlatmayı tercih ediyorum açıkçası daha
anlaşılır hale getirmek istiyorum çünkü
düz Zira araştırmaların sonucunda en
fazla öğreneceğiniz çek kadın kılığında
erkek kılığına girmek Ah ne kadar
yaratıcı erkek kılından kadın kılığına
girmek gibi sıvı ve saçma cümleler olur
sakın Google'dan direk uyu nedir diye
aramayın çok büyük hata bu kostüm
giyiyor olması ve abartılı makyaj
yapıyor olması bir cinsiyete ait
olduğunu göstermez kostümü ve makyajı
cinsiyet yüklemesi yapan insan beynidir
bir nereden faydalanıyor bu anda
bilmiyorum da da Dolayısıyla algılanan
dan çok daha farklı görünebilir
içerisinde İroni vardır gayet yok bu
içerisinde İsyan vardır
bırak aykırıdır ve haykırır bu yüzden
görünen ötesindedir bazen bazı şeyleri
kavrayabilmek için Derine inmek
gerekiyor
Ben lise bittikten sonra Dershane
hayatında birlikte tiyatro eğitimi almak
istedim Çünkü ilk öğretim hayatında ve
lise hayatında okulun tiyatro
etkinliklerinde ve dans gösterileri hep
yer aldım Şimdi öğretmen bu sınıfın
yapacağız Ama ben öğretmenim o beğendim
işte
de annemi ikna ettim ve
Tarlabaşı Bulvarı'nda İstanbul Sanat
Merkezi vardı eski Beyoğlu'nu bilenden
mutlaka eski Tarlabaşı Bulvarı'nda
bilirler Cadde boydan boya seks
işçilerinin çalıştığı bir yerdi Tabi biz
o manzara karşısında Annemle beraber şok
olduk Ben küçüktüm Şok Oldum Annem ilk
defa gördüğü için çok oldu
o gün Sağ Salim atlattık ve eve geldik
annemin ilk tepkisi seni la la oraya
göndermem Yok ya Bana sökmez Tabii ki bu
bir de O tiyatro tutkumu ve sevginin o
kadar farkındaydı ki bu durum karşısında
biraz alımlı olmak durumunda kaldı
eğitimin bitmeye yakın üniversite
kazandım Bolu'ya gittim Okulda da koy
Güzel sanatlar fakültesine bağlı
yaratıcı drama topluluğunda yer aldım
niçin konservatuar okumadın Çünkü
kaşları yüksektir de üniversite okumak
artık liseyi okumak ilköğretim okumak da
bu dönemde çok zor biliyorsunuz ki o
zaman da öyleydi okulum bitti Sonra deli
sorular para kazanacaksın bana babadan
para almayacaksın Baran bu daha kafamda
dönmeye başlayınca e tiyatroda olmak
istiyorum tamam ama tiyatro beni istiyor
mu bu tek taraflı olmuyor istemek Turizm
yapmak istemiyorum Çünkü zaten zorla
okudum sırf aleminin ağzı sussun işte
onlar mutlu olsun abi oğlumuz
okutulabilecek ya pişman mıyım pişman o
Çünkü ilgili olan başka bölümler Keşke
okusaydım dedim kendime ama şu anki
noktaya baktığımız zaman
Bence her şey çok doğru ilerlemiş yoksa
bir drakquin olamayacaktı Nişantaşı'nda
çok sevdiğim tiyatrodan iki Arkadaşım
yaşıyor Kibele ve
atabağ haftanın bir günü ziyarete
gittiğim O ev altı günü yaşadığım ev
haline dönüştü zamanla Ve o dönemde
internette internet bu kadar böyle çok
hani dilden dile dolaşan işte online
eğitimler Ne oldu Biz dönem değil o
zaman
YouTube'da
1998 yılından bu zamana kadar yapılan
Las Palmas kıran kanarya Gala drakquin
yarışmalarını buldum Şu
bu ve bir yerden sonra beni o kadar çok
içine çektik ya o karakterler üç buçuk
dakikadan oluşan müzikli gösteriler
yapıyorlar kendini bir karakter
yaratıyor ve bir hikaye anlatıyorlar bu
çok ilgimi çıktı bir zaman sonra da
artık kendime karakterler atmaya
başladım ve ki hikayeler yazmaya
başladım Şu
ben
buna da tabi arkadaşlarımı anlatıyorum
alt komşumuz Deniz vardı denizin
dıdısının dıdısı olacak ama bunu böyle
anlatmam gerekiyor denizin üniversiteden
arkadaşı İstanbul işe Beyoğlu'ndaki bir
gece kulübünü sahibinin erkek kardeşi şu
onlar çok yakın arkadaşlar bugün arkadaş
toplantı yapıyorlar buluşuyorlar kulübün
eğlence müdürü de orada
da kuvvetlidir aklına çalışıyormuş Deniz
de Bunu duyunca Benim arkadaşım da işte
şovlar izle falan senaryolar yazıyor
deyince tanışmak istemiş Bir sonraki gün
biz eğlence müdürü olan kayhanbey
buluştuk ertesi gün beni provaya soktu
bir sonraki gün sahneye çıkardı tiyatro
gibi bir şey değil ki bu yani ne
yapacağım ben neredeyim Kulesi
gözlemledim insanları gözlemledim gece
hayatına ilk defa girdim gece hayatını
gözlemledim ki orası bambaşka bir dünya
hiç
bir zaman sonra artık kendi şovları mı
yapmaya başladım kendi çoğunu yapabilmem
için de kendi karakterimi Yar atmam
gerekiyordu
oldu Show larımı yapıp polise döndüğümde
Şunu fark etmeye başladım gayet
huzurluyum
empati kurabiliyorum yani empati zaten
kuralında bunu daha fazla
yapar hale geliyorum
kendimi daha iyi ifade edebiliyorum
kendimi çok özgür hissediyorum duygusal
tahribatları ortadan kalkıyor kendime
bir karakter yaratıyor ve o karakterin
içerisinde saklanıyorum Halbuki o da
bana o da Baran yani hepsi Baran bunun
bana çok iyi geldin ruhuma çok iyi
geldiğini fark ettim ve ve asla Ben
bırak vinometre koyun olduğuna karar
verdim biraz öyle olmuş oluyor bu
sanatın drakquin ağzına sıçtım ben çünkü
sevdim
ve sanatın iyileştirici gücüne inandı
Çünkü ben iyileşiyorum
cinselliği çok fazla sorguladığım bir
çocukluk dönemi geçirdim zaten beni Bu
mesleğin içine bucura koyun olma halini
içine çeken cinsellikle alakalı bir şey
olması gerekiyordu bu kadar yoğun Ben de
Türkiye'deki cinsel istismara uğramış
binlerce çocuktan bir tanesiydim altı
yaşında başladı ve defalarca kez tekrar
etti sayısını bile hatırlamıyorum
şiş zaman anlatmadım bunu kimseye bunun
için psikologlara götürüldüm işlerin
için bu çocuk böyle niçin kısmı ise
şuydu çok fazla psikolojik yaptırımını
yaşadım bunun Çünkü bu Öyle kolay değil
yani diyor beden ve bunların en belirgin
olanları birincisi tuvaletin tutam aldım
geldi an bırakırdım ikincisi kardeşime
çok fazla şiddet uyguladım üçüncüsü
kanatarak tırnak yardım
kimse Bunu neden olduğunu anlayamadı
Maalesef bunlar da tek başıma mücadele
etmek zorunda kaldım şıma Aslında dilim
Suskun ama bedenim konuşuyoruz sinyal
veriyor Yahu da bu böyle bir şey var
yani görmüyor musunuz Ama görmediler
işte ne ilaçlarla ne de o tırnakları
sürülen jel ler var ya onlarla tırnak
yemeyi asla bırakamadım bir gün geldi mi
bıraktım 2011 yılında da nasıl bırakmış
olabilir sizin o kadar şey bırak
duramadı şey ne olabilir güç ne olabilir
çok çok çok çok basit bir şey aslında
Çok da yüce bir duygu benim için aşk O
kendini mükemmel gösterme kusursuz
gösterme var ya Salak kusturursun işte
yani kutusu gösteriyorsun ama bıraktırdı
bana tırnak yemeye kardeşine yüzleştim
aynı zamanda bu coğrafyada bir lgbt artı
bileyim
ne olduğunu bilmesem de bir şey olduğunu
biliyorum yani bundan eminim bir şey var
ya
her lgbt artı birey gibi ben de çok
fazla şiddet gördüm ve buna bazı
öğretmenlerin de dahil hiç unutmuyorum
var ya onu bir görsem beden öğretmeni
bana demişti ki kızlarla voleybol
oynayacaksın bundan sonra barandır bir
daha asla beden dersine girmedim
coğrafyayı tarihi hiçbir zaman sevmedim
bunlardan dolayı kendime aileme
daha sonra
toplumun sonra dünyayı sonra gezegene
daha da büyüyor Çünkü her şey sorguladım
diğer de bir yanlışlık vardı mutlaka bir
yerde bir yanlışlık var ama o yanlış ben
değilim Bunu farkına vardım
Allah'tan çok kötü olmadığını fark etmem
yanlıştım kusurlu duydum hatalıydım
eksiktim şeytandan pislik Team Yani
yapıştırılabilecek bütün iğrenç
sıfatları Ben kendime yakıştırdım ve
taşıdım O yüzden ben ilk affetmem
gereken kişinin kendimi olduğunu anladım
herkesin O çok umurunda olan bir
cinsiyetim vardı ya
bu işte bu meslekte geçerli değildi o
yüzden ben mesleği sevdim
Ben kendime en cinsiyet azından bir
karakter yaratımı bir bırak koyun oldum
ve çok daha genelde açılan baktığım
zaman şunu düşünüyorum birbirimizi
sevmek için de birbirimizi anlayabilmek
için ne cins etkinliğinin ne de cinsel
yönelimin bir önemi yok şu anda gayet
güzel anlaşırız Bence ben cinsellik
cinsellikten alınmış vaziyette
sizlerin bu kadın ya da erkek mi diye
sorguladığınız o noktada sizlerle
iletişim kurmaya çalışıyorum
zincirlerimi kopardım duvarlarımı yıktım
yüzleştim Şimdi de sıra aynı tutuyorum
kendim de hem bir kaç fotoğraf
Göstereceğim size
bunu niye yaptım şu zamandaki
gazetecileri eleştirmek adına sizin
satılık kalemlerimizi okumak istemiyorum
sizin Yazdığınız yazıların yer aldığı
gazeteleri ve ancak kendimi aksesuar
yapalım diye bunu yaptım
şu an bu
çürümüş kokmuş
kalpleri cenazesine gidiyorum Eğer öyle
bir şey olmuş olsaydı bu şekilde
giderdim cenaze kostümü mililitre
biliyor musunuz Adem'le Havva döneminden
Bir Efsane Ben lilith olsaydım böyle
olur ha ha
babamdan hepsini söylerdi karı gibi
dondurmaya Ağlama karı gibi bardak
tutmak Arı gibi yukarı gibi Neyse bu
karılarla alıp veremedikleri neyse
erkeklerin bilmiyorum burada dondurma
çekicisi dondurma fışkırtıyor erkeklere
O yüzden on temsilen böyle bir kostüm
yaptım karı gibi bir hakareti bir ancak
iltifat olarak en fazla
kullanabilirsiniz bundan o kadar
etkilendim ki birkaç tane daha var bu
görselden Bu çocuk bu hayvan cihazın çık
minicik benim gibi bunu boynuna ip
bağlayıp gezdiriyor sanki köpek gezdir
gibi aradaki o Güven ilişkisi o
samimiyet beni inanılmaz etkiledi ve
bende bu hayvanı ve o çocuğu dansçılarla
tasvir ederek
kendi görevi kostümü yaptı mı
Ya ben anlatacak bir şeyler buluyorum
burada görebiliyor musunuz bilmiyorum şu
bölgem Parmaklıklar Ardında
Burası dokunamazsınız elle yemezsiniz
burayla ilgili Siz karar veremezsiniz
onu demek istiyorum Bu boyundaki
dikenlerde yaklaşma batar diyor en
aramızdaki mesafe belli olsun Daha ne
kadar söylüyorum anlamıyor musun ayı
gibi bu uzayabilir
Ah ah bu da ne kadar sevdiğiniz işi
yaparsanız yapın işverenlerimizin kölesi
siniz bu net Bu da onu temsil a
sıcaklığın sözcüğünün sizler için çok
daha anlaşılabilir bir hale getirdim
Şöyle ki bir yapı canlandıralım
gözümüzde bir temel atalım ve bu temel
cinsiyetsizlik ya da bütün cinsiyetleri
içerisinde barındırmak olsun
kolonlarını dikelim tariz de
bulunmaktayız de bulmak iğnelemek dalga
geçmek alay etmek gibi bitirebilir
ikincisi duvarları ve aynı duvarları ve
tabuları yıkmak üçüncüsü ise aynı tutmak
Bir de çatımız yerleştirelim buraya Ya
mizah
Bütün bunlar direkt sözcüğünün karşılığı
oluşturuyor yani direk sözcük karakter
olmuş oluyor aslında buraya bir dek un
eklememiz lazım
Bu da ve Boya badana dış cephe kaplama
onu da yaptığın zaman bütünüyle
baktığımda Ya bırak gün sözcüğü oluşmuş
oluyor o zaman direkt sözcüğü soyut
turkun sözcüğü somuttur ikisi bir araya
geldiğinde bambaşka bir boyuttur Peki
şimdi diyebilir miyiz direkt koyun olmak
bir meslektir
diyebilir miyim Hayır ve Köyü olmak bir
varoluş biçimidir bunu sanatla
birleştirirsen Eğer sanat yapmak
istiyorsan drakkuin sahne sanatçısı
dersen ve bundan para kazanıyorsunuz Ama
bu bir meslek olmuş olur yukarıda
gördüğünüz Şu üç Fotoğraftaki kişi
Windows is When When Amerika'da yaşayan
lgbt artı hakları için mücadele vermiş
bir aktris kendisi ona İlk drakquin o
mezarını veren şey resmi tutanaklar o
resmi tutanakta şu yine polise karşı
direndi clary bir eylemde gözaltına
alınarak ifade vermesi istendiğinde
kendisini direkt olarak tanıtıyor ben
bir bırak koydum diyor peki bunu nasıl
çıkıyor Arkadaş ortamında makyajlarla
Costner git kendine karakter yaratıklar
bu düşünüyorum Ben de utanıyorum
Sanırsam buldum ben direk koyunum Aynen
böyle oluyorsa direkt günün sözü binlik
ne bu zamana kadar evrimleşerek geliyor
Çünkü artık Amerika'da hakları var bir
tek bizde yok bildiğim doğru sil
savaştan sanat doğuruyor baktığımızda ve
bu sanat tahta kendi bedeni üzerinde
sadece kendim karar alırım kendim karar
veririm
doğuştan bana atanmış olan cinsiyet
rollerini temsil etmek zorunda değil mi
Nasıl böyle
kalın kalın çiziyor ormağ Şafi cansı
maaş ajansında aynı yolun yolcusu
1969 yılında stonewall ayaklanmaları
unda yine haklarını elde etmek için
verdikleri mücadeleyi kazanan örgütü
temsilcisi
dilim dorsenin nihayete Erdi yemediği
işi
canım aşkım benim Nihayet ağır duruyor
Emeğe saygı duruşu ister misiniz Şimdi
ne be
Madam satır Rio de jenerio oluyo
karnavalında yürüyen ilk drakquin
Huysuz Virjin Seyfi Dursunoğlu
Türkiye'nin ilk durak oyuna
halt Aslında hepimiz onu komik bir
karakter olarak yani yaratmış olduğu
karakteri komik buluyoruz eğleniyoruz
Halbuki bilinçaltınıza öyle bir işledi
ki ünsüz vereceğim İnsanların birbirine
seks bile demeye utandığım bir dönemde
bunu konuşabilir tartışa bir hale
getirdi topluma aynı tuttu konuşuluyor
konuşuluyor
birisine bir espri yapıyor içerisinde
sesin
hemen bir kavgalar gürültüler şimdi
böyle bir espri geldiği zaman
komikmiş İşte o dönemde onu yapmış oldu
oldu drakquin Barbie dhu sizin
Türkiye'nin ilk drakoni fakat Türkiye'de
çalışan iftira Queen değil Bond White
Dragon babet Osmanlı'nın son döneminde
İstanbul'da Pera Palas Oteli'nin
Karşısında bir Garden Bar var bu Garden
bardağı haywire Walker ve trapez
sanatçısı olarak çalışıyor hayvan Walker
da bu ip cambazı var ya ona bir akrabası
Yani bir gün bir uzay belgeseli
seyrettim bu uzay belgesel tabi gayet
sıradan bir belgesi ama ben sıradan
değilim
bütün inanç sistemi değişti Herşey olan
inancım değişti
kişisel sorunlardan zaten aramıştım daha
fazla Evrensel çerçevede bakmaya
başladım
ve şunu anladım kimsenin hayatı hiç
kimsenin hayatına önemli değil bu
dünyada milyarlarca insan gelmiş ve
geçmiş
kimsenin acısı hiç kimsenin acısından
büyük değil Olamaz da zaten Şebnem
Ferah'ın çok sevdiğim bir şarkısı var
diyor ki
acılarımız farklı olabilir ama
gözyaşlarımızın tadı aynı ve bir gün
aynanın karşısına geçtim kendime Şu
soruyu sordum Bunu sorarken çok ağladım
Çünkü gözlerin içine bakarak konuşmak
gerçekten o çok başka bir şeymiş Sen
kimsin Albert Einstein diyor ki yalnızca
aptallara göre insanlar değildin ör
cinsiyet mezhep meslek renk gibi en az 8
kategoriye ayrılırlar Halbuki durum Hiç
bu kadar Komplike değildir insanlar
sadece ikiye ayrılırlar iyi insanlar ve
kötü insanlar bu kadar basit ve ben iyi
insan olabilmek için elimden gelenin
fazlasını yapıyorum ne kadar iyi insan
oldum ya da oluyorum bu Tabii ki
tartışılır Ama şundan o kadar eminim ki
ya bu hayattan bir aptal olarak
gitmeyeceğim yine Albert Einstein en çok
sevdiğim bir sözü tam kafanın şurasında
yazıyor dövmesini yaptırdım burada diyor
ki doğanın derinliklerine Bak işte o
zaman her şey daha iyi anlayacaksın